blackbeard akainu shanks who will be the
final boss of one piece oda sensei has
treated us to some perfectly punishable
builds throughout one piece but as we
near the final saga we can probably
count the major enemies that luffy will
beat down on one hand so today we'll
explore who we most want to see luffy go
toe to toe with as we wonder will we
ever get a punch as satisfying as the
one where he knocked the color right out
of san charlos the two foes at the top
of everyone's list are of course a kainu
and blackbeard what makes them the
perfect final opponent for luffy is that
both blackbeard and akainu are the
perfect representatives of their
factions in the one piece world oh also
quickly massive shout out to blackbird
and skyberry my two subscribers of the
day thanks for hitting subscribe for new
content and helping me raise my bouncy
let's start with akainu cause he is the
quintessential marine as the fleet
admiral he represents everything that
this organization stands for and he is
the de facto leader ignoring as he
sometimes does the gorosei he is a
believer in absolute justice in
zakazuki's eyes no crime should go
unpunished all pirates automatically are
criminals and he is the appointed judge
jury and executioner as much as enes
lobby would like to have a say in that
even if he fundamentally disagrees with
the gorosei or the celestial dragons he
will do everything in his power to
uphold the order that the world
government represents according to him a
world must be founded on strict rules
and authority without submitting to this
ordered hierarchy the world will descend
into anarchy and chaos a chaos that the
world of piracy embodies for him and to
him this doesn't extend only to pirates
that inflict actual violence upon
innocent people like the donkey hot
pirates even the carefree adventuring
that the straw hat crew engages in risks
corroding the balance of society and so
this of course makes him the perfect
counter to luffy who believes that
everyone should be free to choose their
own destinies and follow their dreams to
party to eat to the fill and to
adventure akainu would of course stomp
all these things out in service of
making a more tightly structured world
our first introduction to akaino shows
us just how far he's willing to go in
the name of absolute justice on the
island of o'hara he single-handedly
killed a ship full of innocent citizens
fleeing the buster call none of the
people there were even the librarians
who held the secrets of the ponyglyphs
in fact these evacuees left robin to die
on the island so they could themselves
escape however akainu felt that even the
smallest chance that someone leaving the
island held the librarian secrets posed
too great a risk to the world government
and so to the horror of even another
admiral like aokiji he just destroyed
the ship along with everyone on it
blackbeard on the other hand is of
course the perfect representative of the
world of piracy like luffy he is one of
the yonko the four emperors of the new
world and a prime candidate in the race
to find the one piece if you were to ask
a random person on the street to name
one pirate a real live one chances are
pretty high they'd say blackbeard likely
they might not even know the name of any
other real real-life pirates honestly
they'd soon have come up with captain
jack sparrow before they actually got to
end bonnie or francis drake's oda sensei
gave marshall the teach the title of
blackbeard because he embodies the
classic image of a pirate at least he
represents a certain type of pirates in
the original romans dawn one shots
before the serialization of one piece as
we know it oda sensei actually defined
two separate classifications of pirates
pirates that are looking for adventure
on the high seas like the straw hats
were termed peas main pirates whereas
pirates who pillage and plunder were
called morganeers by oda and so while
oda sensei didn't keep the terminology
we can still see echoes of this
definition in the different approaches
to piracy that different crews take and
the blackbeard pirates are definitely in
the morgan ear plundering type of camp
now you might think that we haven't
really seen him do much in the way of
classic pillaging and plundering but the
very first reference we get to black bit
in the series actually confirms this
back on drum island dalton refers to
blackbeard ransacking the kingdom in
fact it was the terrifying power of the
blackbeard pirates that caused wapol to
flee the country and take all the
doctors with him setting us up for
chopper's introduction and let's just
take another minute to once again praise
the almighty godas foreshadowing because
we received whispers of blackbeard long
before luffy and blackbeard's chance
encounter on jaya by now making their
home on beehive island the blackbeard
pirates are creating their version of a
pirate paradise lawless and chaotic he
allows his 10 titanic captains to run
wild in a new world as they amass power
by collecting more and more devil fruits
so how are both of these characters the
perfect final enemies for luffy while at
their core both of these antagonists are
complete opposites to luffy's core
philosophy luffy believes in freedom
above all else freedom to travel to eat
to party to adventure and yeah freedom
to live a kaino and the marines restrict
the freedom of people across the seas of
one piece while they may protect the
people from dangerous violent pirates
they also enact exploitative taxes
restrict travel and even run protection
for the slave-holding celestial dragons
blackbeard on the other hand instead of
being opposed to luffy is more like the
other side of the same coin just like
luffy teach believes in a kind of
freedom but it's a freedom that allows
someone to use their power to infringe
on the freedom of another in other words
kind of a rule of the strongest if he
wants so while luffy uses his freedom to
uplift others and grant them the same
freedoms he has blackbeard uses his
freedom towards his own personal gains
and pushing others down and it's not
just that their philosophies are
diametrically opposed that set a kind
and blackbeard up as the perfect
antagonist for luffy the stakes here are
personal as well these two characters
are both directly responsible for aces
death a kainu very literally did kill
ace and to add to luffy's personal
grudge against the fleet admiral he
killed aes while ace was trying to
protect luffy however the war at marine
ford never would have occurred in the
first place if it weren't for the
actions of blackbeard he was the one who
captured ace and turned him over to the
marines in order to claim his status as
a shichibukai this too partly falls onto
luffy's shoulders because blackbeard was
actually pursuing luffy at the time that
ace confronted him and so before the end
of the series i think we can all agree
that we do need to see luffy take his
revenge on these powerful foes another
figure that will probably see luffy
fight before the end of one piece is the
mysterious insama so far really almost
nothing is known about the secret true
ruler of the world government given that
they've only appeared in a single
chapter of the manga there is still a
lot that we have to learn about this
shadowy figure but given that they're
the head of the world government they
appear to be very much final boss
material yes luffy does have a personal
grudge against the kainu but eem is a
kaino's boss's boss and the real
decision maker behind all the actions of
the marines so if luffy actually wants
to bring freedom to the rest of the
world the only way he will be able to do
that is go through and we also know that
im sama has it out for luffy as well i
mean yes we don't really know too much
about eem's true motivations but
whenever i rip up a picture of someone's
face it usually means i don't really
like them we also have a few wild cards
though these are figures that luffy
could possibly fight but we really don't
know yet at this point whether they're
enemy or friends a big one that people
of course have been theorizing about
including me is the possibility that
luffy will fight his childhood hero
shanks based on shanks's weird
connection to the gorosei some fans have
speculated that shanks's motivation
might be less than good perhaps he will
actually turn out to be a true rival or
even the main villain to luffy for the
throne of pirate king i actually just
released a video about just this
possibility because i truly believe that
one way or another shanks and luffy will
clash at some point very soon in the
story who knows maybe they'll just have
a good spirited davy backfight leading
to the 12th and final straw hats lucky
room or it might be an all-out battle
then of course we have absolutely wild
predictions as we know oda sensei is
famous for his ridiculous left turns and
unpredictability
so who else could luffy still have to
fight i mean the sky is the limit really
perhaps he'll have a rematch against one
of the series first villains and fellow
yonko buggy the clown after all at the
rate that buggy is failing upwards at
the moment he might be a true rival for
the position of pirate king at this
point maybe he'll also be forced into a
conflict with a marine that he has close
ties to since he is after all still a
pirate we've built up a metric ton of
hatred for a kainu but wouldn't it be
heartbreaking to see him have to go all
out against kobe or smoka or even his
grandfather garp after all people have
really been sleeping on kobe future
admiral the secret final villain that
oda has foreshadowed since chapter two
his future power only makes sense given
that he is a child of big mom as
evidenced by his pink hair
okay maybe i might have to lay off the
coffee i might be hitting those theories
a little bit too hard and i wasn't being
quite serious but the fight i'm probably
looking forward to the most is in fact
shanks and if you want to understand why
this clash between luffy and shanks is
inevitable you should really not miss
out on this video right here